A surface is a container for
your content and provides grouping and
separation from other elements, but
there are other lighter weight ways
to visually group the content.
So when should you create a surface?
Let's look at an example.
Here, we have a surface for the app
bar and a surface for each list item.
The issue here is that the surfaces
act as a kind of cognitive speed bump.
While it's useful to visually separate
the app bar from the content,
placing each item on
an individual surface
lowers your speed in
scanning down the list.
A much cleaner approach is to simply
draw the content on a single service
using a subtle separator.
Conversely, in this example, placing
each of these very different items onto
their own separate surface let's you
visually process each one individually.
A good rule of thumb is if content
is homogeneous, when scanning and
comparison will be important, then it
likely belongs on a single surface.
If you need to present a collection
of heterogeneous items,
then individual surfaces
are appropriate.
Directing attention is
a powerful technique, but
needs to be used judiciously.
Having too many separate surfaces on
a screen at once can be distracting.
As a very rough rule of thumb,
try not to have more than around
five surfaces on the screen at once.